[موسيقى]
اوقاتكم اهلا بكم الى اخبار الساعه
نبداوها في ابرز العناوي
استمرار امنيه شمال سوريا
ويترك الاكراد تحت النيران
مفاجاته كاس العالم مستمره منتخب
الساموراي يهزم الالمان والماتادور
الاسباني يدق المرمى الكوستريكي
في ايران حرب وشوارع في المدن الكرديه
نظام يرفع وتيره الخمر والمحتاجون يردون
بالدعوه لاضراب العام
روسيا كان في مطوبه امكاناتها العسكريه
ورساله ضغط جديده على اداره البايدن
لتزويد اوكرانيا بالمسيره
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم التاهب والاستنفار يسيطرني على
شمال السوري على الجانب التركي من الحدود
دبابات وجنود خلف المساريس بانتظار الضوء
الاخضر للهجوم هجوم بريه قد يعيد اجواء
الحرب الى سوريا التي لا تزال
لماركاما ما بقي منها وعلى الضفه الاخرى
يقف الاكراد على قوه هاتي بركان استعدادا
لمعركه لن تقتصر تداعيتها على بعض مناطق
فقط قد يصل الامر الى حد كارثه في الشمال
السوري
اذا الغرات الجويه على مواقع الاكراد في
سوريا العراق مستمره العمليه التركيه اخذه
بالتصعيد هذا ما المحال اليه الرئيس سعد
تركي رجب طيب اردوغان باصراره على ما تقوم
به بلاد ضد من وصفهم بالارهابيين حيث اكد
ان تركيا عازمه اكثر من اي وقت مضى على
تامين حدودها الجنوبيه واساسهاجم المسلحين
داخل تركيا وخارجيها اردوغان جددت تلويح
ايضا بتنفيذ العمليه البريه في الوقت
الملائم وربما قريب
جدا
على الجانب الاخر السوريه تتاهب قوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه وتستعد للهجمات التركيه
رئيس المجلس التنفيذي للاداره الذاتيه
بشمال وشرق سوريا عبد حامد المهباش حذر من
ان الوضع يتجه نحو كارثه في حال استمرار
هجمات انقره على المنطقه مشيرا الى ان
تركيا تسعى لخلق فوضى بدوره حضر قائد قوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه مظلوم عبدي من اتساع
نطاق الحرب لتشمل جميع المناطق في حاله
تنفيذي تركيا هجومها البريه واعلن ان قوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه او التنسيق مع التحالف
الدولي داعيا الجيش الجيش النظامي
في مواجهه تركيا
العمليه البريه تقلق بالفعل قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه التي رجحت النير يتركز الهدوم
على كوباني لاهميتها بالنسبه للاكراد
والاطراف فقد اعلنت انقره ان المره الامن
الذي بدات به اقامته سيشمل تل رفعت ومنبج
وعين العرب كوباني الهدف من السيطره على
منبج هو انهاء الوجود الكرديه غرب نهر
الفرات اما الهدف من السيطره على كوباني
راس العين بتل ابيض وبتوازي تواصل تركيا
استهدف ابرزها اكثر من اربعين قريه شمال
شرق سوريا وفوباني وغارات استهدفت ايضا
قاعده التحالف في الحسكه بالاضافه الى ضرب
اهداف النفطيه في القامشلي القصف التركي
طالع ايضا مقرا لقوات الاسد في قاعده
الروسيه تقع في شمال شرق سوريا وزير
الدفاع التركي خلص هيكار بدوره افاد بان
في الجويه التي تنفذها انقره اسفرت عن
تحديث
254 مسلحا واصابت 471 هدفا تابعا
له
في ظل التصعيد التركيه واجهت روسيا تحذينا
عبر المفاوض ذلك سندر لافرنتيفا الذي دعا
تركيا الى الامتناع عن شنه هجوم بريه شامل
في سوريا وقال ان مثل هذه التحركات قد
تؤدي الى تصاعد العنف
رغم دعوه روسيا كالكلاتي يبدو ان هناك عجز
امريكي روسي واضح لوقف التوغل التركي
الجديد في سوريا نهائيا فما هو السبب
صحيفه بوليتكو الامريكيه نقلت عن محللين
قولهم ان المصالح ربما قبل الجهود واشنطن
و موسكو بالضغط على انقره بالنسبه لامريكا
اشار التقرير الى انها قد لا تقاوم بشده
لعمليه التركيه لانها تريد من انقر قبول
انضمام السويد وفنلندا الى التحالف
العسكريه الغربي اما الجانب الروسيه
دخلتها المصالح ايضا حيث كشفت الصحيفه ان
موسكو تدخل ملايين
للاقتصاد التركي واقطاع الطاقه في البلاد
ما يدعم اردوغان قبل انتخابات العام
المقبل وان الرئيس التركي قد يرد الدين
بقوله اخيرا بشار الاسد في حاكم شرعي
لسوريا وفريقه صحيفه
من الخبر العميده اسعد الزعبي المحلل
العسكري
والاستراتيجي اهلا بك يعني بدايه عميد
اسعد اليوم اذا ما تحدثنا انه الضغط سواء
الامريكي او الروسي على تركيا يبدو انه
خجل بمعنى ان كل الدولتين كل من روسيا
وكذلك الولايات المتحده تريد لهذه العمليه
الا تبدا ولكنها لن تضغط بشكل
الاوضاع السياسيه العالميه حقيقه ان تشير
الى ان هناك كثير من الاوراق الموجوده في
تركيا وبالتالي امريكا بحاجه الى جزء من
هذه الاوراق وكذلك الامر بالنسبه لي همم
تحاول استفاده من هذه الاوراق في عمليه
همم
العمليه او لكن اعتقد ان هناك ربما تكون
مباحثات يعني
سواء امس او اليوم تتحدث ربما ان يكون
هناك عمليه جزئيه لكنني من الناحيه
العسكريه اقرا الوضع العسكري تماما يعني
الضربات الجويه الكثيفه لا تشير الى عمليه
بريه بمعنى انه ربما تنتهي العمليه
العسكريه
فقط تقتصر على ضربات الجويه فتكون بذلك قد
يعني الى حد ما قد
يعني هل تؤدي غرضها هذه العمليه المحدوده
بالنسبه لتركيا اما انها ستذهب الى ابعد
من ذلك
هي الحقيقه يعني
دائما العمل العسكري يعني نهايته يجب ان
تؤدي الى هدف سياسي والهدف السياسي اعتقد
هناك كثير من الموافقه الروسيه والامريكيه
يعلم ممارسه الضغط
الجوي يعني الوسيله الوحيده من اجل دفع
التنظيم قصد باتجاه النظام باتجاه القبور
والشرطه النظام وبالتالي يعني هذا ما
تريده موسكو وهذا ما يعني يسعى اليه
النظام لكن بالتاكيد ايضا امريكا تكون
قد انها منع التنفيذ عمليه بريه يعني اذا
الاطراف الثلاثه لهم مصلحه في ان تكون
هناك ضربات جويه توفي بالغرض وتحقق يعني
هدفا تركيا جزءا هدفا روسيا وهمم الى حد
ما ارضى لامريكا وعدم يعني التجاوز الخط
الامريكي او الضوء الاحمر الامريكي هذا ما
اعتقد ضربات جويه فضربات جويه يعني لم
تكون ضربات تشير الى امكانيه تمهيد جوي او
حتى دعم قوي وبالتالي عندما نتحدث على ان
هناك بالعلم العسكري ان هناك عمليه جويه
يجب ان نقرا بكثافه الطلعات ونوع الطلعات
ونوع الدخان ومكان الهدف لنقول ان هناك
عمليه تراث عمليه بريه تراثه هذا
العمل ام لا لكن يعني حقيقه اقول يعني من
خلال خبره العسكريه كطيار اقول ان هذه
الضربات فقط عباره عن ضربات همم ربما تثير
او يعني تنفذ اخراج همم قد يكون الى مستوى
35% لكن هذا ال 35% اعتقد سيرجيو اليوم
الذي تحدث
يعني ربما تكون هناك همم عمليه جزئيه او
الاقبال او بمعنى يعني القبول بما جرى
وكذلك الامر بالنسبه لتحدي الامريكيه يعني
بالتاكيد لن تقبل بدخوله قوات تركيا الى
قواعدها قريبه من الحسكه والخامشي وكذلك
الامر وهو الهدف الاخير هو الاكبر بالنسبه
لروسيا ان تعقق ضغطا على تنظيم من اجل
العبد النظام او القبول او على الاقل فتح
باب حوار اكثر النظام لذلك يعني انا كثير
تماما ربما من خبره اقول يعني ان لا امين
او يعني لست واثقا من عمله امين الى عدم
تنفيذ عمليه شكرا جزيلا للعميد سعد
الزعبيه المحلل العسكريه
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله على وقع استمرار الاحتجاجات في
ايران وحملتها قمعها من قبل النظام اعلنت
وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه ترضع عقوبه على
ثلاثه مسؤولين امنيين ايرانيين تتعلق هذه
العقوبات بنتهاك حقوق الانسان حيث عزات
وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه ذلك الى حمله
طهران الامنيه ضد المحتاجين قال اجراءات
العدوانيه المتزايده ضد الشعب الايراني
وفق الوزاره
في المدن الكرديه تحديدا في ايران تحولت
الشوارع الى ساحه حرب للمواجهات بين
المحتجين وقوه الامن ومع تصاعد زخم
الاحتجاجات دعا نشطاء للاضراب العام ردا
على قمع قوات الامن اتجاه المدن الكرديه
غرب البلاد فيما ارسلت السلطات الايرانيه
القوات لفرد المزيد من القمه في تلك المدن
نشطاء افاده ان قوات الامن فرضت اجراءات
امنيه مشدده عند مداخل المدن الكرديه
ومنعت ايصال المساعدات الطبيه الاغاثيه
للجرحى
[تصفيق]
ينضم الينا من السوق صالح مسؤول الاعلام
في الحزب الديمقراطيه الكردستانيه
الايرانيه اهلا بك سيدات يعني بدي اسالك
لماذا التركيز الان على هذه المدن تحديدا
الكرديه
دراسه 40
هنالك نظر امنيه تجاه الاكراد من قبل
النظام وهذا بسبب الحقائق تاريخيه ولكن
عدت انظمه مختلفه فات لها نفس الاراء
هم كل ما يقوم به الاكراد
التعامل معه من خلال القوات الامنيه
والاكراد في ايران عندما يتظاهر هارون في
كل يوم فهذا يمثل تهديدا لان النظام من
وجهه نظارهم السبب الثاني هو ان همم
روابطه بين الاكراد والاحزاب الكرديه وهذه
العلاقات تاريخيه وقويه
وعندما يكون هناك اي عمل سياسي
من قبل الافراد النظامي يقرر رقم معاهم
مباشره ثالثا هذه التظاهرات بدات عندما
بحث امين هذه الفتاه الكرديه الشابه قتلت
وحزبي انا واحزاب كرديه اخرى
طالبوا السكان بيتظاهره عشان يضرب عام
واستجابوا بشكل جيد اما السبب الرابع فني
النظام يقمع الاكراد لانهم للاسف همم كافه
الاقليات مثل العرب والبلوش له تكليفه اقل
على ان النظام واقصد التكلفه فيما خصم
منظمات حقوق الانسان
بشكل عام
من خلال قمعي الاكراد
فالنظام يبعثه برساله الى النظام الايراني
مفادها اوقفوا اتظاهرات طيب لاسالك من
يخرج بهذه التظاهرات والى اي مدى يكون نفس
الشارع طويل في مواجهه القمع الامن
هذه مثلا مثيره للغايه حاليا هناك تظاهرات
ليس فقط في الشوارع اعفاهم هنالك حتى في
القرى وهذا يعني
جراني اندروجين فورس
الايراني
فقط في المدن بين انتشرت حتى الى القرى
وهذا يعني تركيز اقل على شوارع المدن
الكبرى وبالتالي في بامكاني السكان الخروج
في كل يوم لتظاهر في المدن وكذلك في القرى
وهذا بالتالي يعني
الشعب كله وقرر ان يكون هنالك تغير في
النظام فيبدا انهار باضطرابات عامه ثم
ينتهي اليوم باللتظاهرات وفي اليوم التالي
يكون هنالك
يا اجرين
ومره اخرى اضراب عام وتظاهرات
نعم شكرا جزيلا للسيدات صالح مسؤول
الاعلام في الحزب الديمقراطيه
الكردستانيلا
[موسيقى]
مجريات الحربيه في اوكرانيا قد يغيرها
تقدم او اختفاء كل طرفي الحرب السلاح يلعب
دورا مهما في قلب موازين المعركه وزاره
الدفاع البريطانيه رجحت ان روسيا استهلكت
كل مخزونها الحالي تقريبا من الاسلحه
الايرانيه الصنع للدقه اكثر المسيارات
مشيره الى ان الهجمات الروسيه تمزج بين
استخدام الطائرات المسيره وانظمه الاسلحه
التقليديه التي يمكن اعاده استخدامها
واشنطن ايضا ايضا ذلك هو قال وزير الدفاع
على ملكيه
القوات الروسيه تعاني نقصا كبيرا في ذائر
المدفعيه
لكن النائبه رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي
ديمتري مدفيدفنوفا ما تم تداوله عن نضب
مخزون روسيا من الاسلحه مشددا على
امتلاكها ما يكفي لضربي وكبح الجميع وفق
تعبيره مدريد ذا توجه الى من سماهم
الاعداء الذين يرصدون عدد الاطلاقات
الصاروخيه الروسيه ويحاولون تحديدا
احتياطيها من الاسلحه والذخيره ودعاهم
لعدم عقدها امالهم على الوضوء الامكانات
الروسيه
المقابل لتقرير لصحيفه بول ستريت جورنال
الامريكيه كشف عن ضغوطات الامريكيه جديده
لمساعده اوكرانيا عسكريا ضغوطات جاءت من
العديد من الاعضاء البارزين بمجلس شيوخ
الذين طالبوا في رساله لاداره الرئيس جو
بايدن بضروره منح اوكرانيا طائره دون طيار
مسلحه الهدف قلب المسار الاستراتيجي للحرب
لصالح كيب ومواجهه استخدام روسيا للطائرات
الايرانيه الصحيفه اوضحتنا وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه رفضت طلبا اوكرانيا للحصول على
مثل هذه الطائرات من قبل هذه الشعور
المسؤولون الامريكيون بالقلم من امكانيات
سرقه التكنولوجيا الموجوده في السلاح لكن
رفض واشنطن مره اخرى لتسليم اوكرانيا
مسيرات قد يكون له تبريد اخر مره تدفع
الولايات المتحده باتجاه المفاوضات بين
موسكو وكيف وسط مخاوف بشان التداعيات
الاقتصاديه العالميه لهذه الحرب
[موسيقى]
من واشنطن ينضم الينا الدكتور غريب استاذ
الاستاذ في العلاقات الدوليه دكتور اهلا
بك يعني الخوف الامريكي هل هو مبرر من
ربما سرقه هذه التكنولوجيا او معرفتها ام
انها بالفعل ضغوط امريكيه على الجلوس الى
طاوله التفاوض
فعلا اعتقد اولا ان هناك اكثر من سبب ومن
بينها مثلا انه حتى قبل الرحلات الاخيره
عندما كانت هناك بعض القوه تدفع باتجاه
تسليم او بيع مثل هذه الطائرات
الاداره تدفع على
ثمن هذه الصواريخ
هذه الطائرات
وكان الخشيه من ان هذه التقنيه قد تقع همم
في ايدي الروس لان هذه الطائرات قادره من
اوكرانيا على الوصول الى العمق الروسي او
الى الداخل الروسي
يقولوا المسؤولون العسكريون الامريكيون
لان قدرات الروس العسكريا على اسقاط هذه
المسيرات هي كبيره وبالتالي فان هذا
العامل كان موجود من قبل ولكن اعتقد كما
تفضل حضرتك
عوامل اخرى عامل اخر مهمه وان انا الان
بدانا نرى بعض القوه حتى داخل الى الاصوات
وايضا القوه بعضها حتى في الكونجرس وفي
اوساط الراي العام تعتقد بانه سيكون من
الصعب على اوكرانيا استعاده الاراضي وان
استمرار هذه الحرب سيكون مكلفه ليس فقط
لاوكرانيا بل حتى
الدول الغربيه نفسها ولذلك وان المفاوضات
قد تكون ضروريه وعلى الرغم من ان الاداره
تراجعت عن مثل هذه المواقف خاصه تلك التي
ادل بها الجرار الملي رئيس هيئه الاركان
المشتركه الذي عبر عن اهميه
المصالحه او
المفاوضات الدبلوماتيه همم ولكن اعتقد ان
هذا الموضوع هو ايضا الموضوع فعلا مهم وان
الاداره تاخذ بعين الاعتبار ان يعني
استخدام هذه الصواريخ قد يعقد الامور اكثر
ويدفع
الرؤوسا او شراسه طيب هل تعتقد بانه
بالفعل روسيا نفذ ذيرتها
بالمسيرات وبالتالي هذا سينعكس على واقع
الارض بالتحور من صالحها الى خساره
الاراضي
فعلا هذا ايضا هو احد الاسئله احدى احد
احد ابرز همم
المسؤولين الامريكيين السابقين في
الكونجرس وهو من الخبراء همم في هذه
الشؤون قال نقطتين مهمتنا الاولى قال بان
هل ستغير هذه الصواريخ عفوا هذه المسير
سيارات هل ستغير النتائج والوضع على الارض
في اوكرانيا هذا هو السؤال الثاني السؤال
همم الاخر الذي قاله انه هل يمكننا هنا
يتحدث عن الاداره الامريكيه على الموقع
الامريكي هل يمكننا فعلا ان نتعامل مع
نتائج استخدام هذه المسيرات مع الروس
وبالتالي فانه يبدو ان هناك ايضا مسائيتين
مسالتين
وقال اذا كانت جواب نعم فعندنا اذا سنرى
بيع هذه المسير سيارات ولكن حتى الان على
الاقل وزاره الدفاع والبيت الابيض يعرض هل
هذه المسيره شكرا نالي الدكتور رائد من
غريب الاستاذ في العلاقات الدوليه كنت
تبعنا من واشنطن
بالحديث عن الدعم العسكريه في حرب
اوكرانيا قال وزير الدفاع البولنديه انه
طلب من المانيا ارسال قاذفات صواريخ
باتريوت معروضه على بولندا الى اوكرانيا
واضف على تويتر بعد مزيد من الهجمات
الصاروخيه الروسيه طلبت من المانيا نقله
بطاريات فاتريوت معروضه على بولندا الى
اوكرانيا ونشرها على حدودها الغربيه وقالت
بولندا انها ستقترح نشرها دفاتر صواريخ
باتريوت اضافيه قرب حدودها معه اوكرانيا
تعاقبات عرضا من عرضا
[موسيقى]
على ابواب الشتاء لم تعد المساعدات
الاوكرانيا عسكريه فقط اذا تعالت الدعوات
لمساعدتها بالتدفئه قبل الشتائها القاسي
سيما في وقت يعيش فيه ملايين الاوكرانيين
مصاعب الظلام والبرد واحنفيات المياه
الجافه هذا كله بسبب موجه الصواريخ
الروسيه التي استهدفت الشارع الماضي
التحتيه الاوكرانيه ومحطات الطاقه
وبسبب الضربه الروسيه التي تستهدف محطات
الطاقه قرر البرلمان الاوروبي تصنيفه
روسيا دوله راعيه للارهاب في قرار غير
ملزم لكنه اذا رمزيه كبيره جاء في القرار
ان الضربات العسكريه الروسيه على اهداف
مدنيه مثل البن التحتيه للطاقه ومستشفيات
ومدارس وملاج في اوكرانيا تنتهي كالقانون
الدولي الرئيس الاوكرانيه
وادعى الى عصر روسيا في جميع المحافظ
الدوليه
[موسيقى]
اربكت عمليه القدس الاسرائيليين اليوم
وهزت تجهزتهم الامنيه فبعد الهجومين الذين
استهدف محطتين حافلات في القدس واسفره عن
مقتل اسرائيلي واصابه 18 على الاقل
استنفرت قوات الامن الاسرائيليه واعتقلت
الشرطه 3 فلسطينيين يشتبه بصلاتهم
بالعمليه المعلومات الاوليه وفقه الشرطه
تشير الى ان الانفجار عن تفجير العامه
مداخل مدينه القدس لكن التحقيقات لا تزال
جاليه
[موسيقى]
ياتي الانفجاراننا او واسطه تصاعد التوتر
بين الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين وسلسله
اعتقالات وقتل ومداهمات اسرائيليه في
الضفه الغربيه في الاشهر الاخيره فصائل
فلسطينيه اعتبرت ان هذه العمليه تاتي في
سياق الرد الطبيعيه على جرائم الاحتلال في
المقابل اسرائيل تواعدت بملاحقه المنافدين
ما ينذر بمزيد من التصعيد في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه سيامو ان النائب الاسرائيلي
اليمني اثمار
المرشح لتولي وزاره الداخليه في حكومه
بنيامين نتنياهو دعى الى العوده الى سياسه
الاغتيالات تجاه الفلسطينيين ومن موقع
التفجيرين في القدس دعا ايضا
الى اغلاق جميع السجون الامنيه ومن
الزياره عن الاسرى
[موسيقى]
لدينا ايضا في اخبار الساعه توتير از من
ازمه الى اخرى شركات كبرى تطير بعيدا عن
العصفور الازرق
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله الهاربون من تويتر اكثر من
الصامدين بين الجدراني هي اخرهم المعلنون
الكبار فبعده هروب الموظفين وتسريح اخرين
هرب المعلنون وهو ما سيشكل ضربه الليله
ماسك ولشركه التي تشكل الاعلانات فيها 90%
من ارادهتها
ورشه التغيير التي عاصفه بتويتر فتحت باب
الموقع عالم اسرائيل عمال مقالون او
مستقلون من جهه ومن الجهه الاخرى يهرب
المعلنون العشرات من كبار المعلمين على
تويتر اوقفوا اعلاناتهم اكثر من 33 جهه
تسويقا كبرى لم تعلن على تويتر في
الاسبوعين الماضيين وفق صحيفه واشنطن
بوستا لتشهد صفحات العصفور الازرق غياب
افضل 14 معلنا على المنصه من ضمنهم شركات
جيب وجنر موتورز التاني اوقفت الاعلانات
المدفوعه على تويتر بشكل مؤقتا وفي خطوه
مماثله اصدرت مجموعه امكم للدعايه
والتسويق في الثانيه عشر من نوفمبر توصيه
لعملائها بوقف انفاقهم مؤقتا على اعلانات
تويتر
من خمسه الاف عميلا في 70 دوله بينهم
ماكدونالدز وابل ولم يعرف انتبه على اي من
عملائها التوصيات هذه الخطوات والصفات
بالمؤشر على تقلب المعلمين وشكوك الوكالات
والعلامات التجاريه حول مستقبل الموقع بعد
الاستحواذ الفوضووي للملياردير الون ماسك
عليه ورغم مساعي ماسك الحثيثه لخفض
التكاليف وايجاد اشكال بديله للارادات
يعتمد تويتر بشده على الاعلانات التي شكلت
90% من ايراداته العام الماضي في مصر صاحب
منصه الجديد يرجع الانخفاض الكبيره
بالايرادات الى ضغوط مجموعات حقوقيه على
المعلنين لمقاطعه الخدمه لحين توضيح كيفيه
تحكم تويتر بالمعلومات المضلله وخطاب
الكراهيه
معناها من سان فرانسيسكو مراسل العربيه
حسين الطود حسين الى متى تكون هذه المره
الاعلانات وشركات الكبرى ضربه
لتر الطائر الازرق
تحيه لك عادل الضربات تتوالى على ايرون
ماسك وهذه اييي موضوع الاعلانات وموضوع
الاتهامات هي كرات الثلج في الحقيقه تكبر
يوما بعد يوم يبدو ان لنا ماسك سيواجه
الكثير من المصاعب معها لاسيما في ظل
الضغوط الكبيره التي تمارسها جمعيات
حقوقيه وايضا ناشطون يتهمون ماسك بانه من
خلال سياسته الجديده هو يفتح الباب امام
همم
الخطاب الكراهيه خاصه بعدما اعاده تفعيل
حساب الرئيس السابق ضمن ترامب وفي كل في
كل ذلك ما زلنا نحن هنا في سان فرانسيسكو
نحاول التواصل مع الشركه همم
بشكل مباشر ولكنهم يرفضون اليوم ايضا
حاولت الدخول الى همم الشركه حول التواصل
مع احد همم من المسؤولين فيها لكنهم ايضا
كما هي كما مات معتادا همم يرفضون ذلك
وعندما يرون الكاميرا فورا ياتي يقترب
رجال الامن على المكلفين
بالمنطقه ليكون لنا ممنوع التصوير
سالتهم اليوم هل يمكنني فقط ان هذا بدون
كاميرا قلي يمكنك ان تجرب ولكن عندما وصلت
الى باب همم الشركه هنا في سان فرانسيسكو
رفض موظفون استقبال حتى فتح الباب لي
عندما عرفوا انني صحفي قالوا لن نتكلم
احاول رصد اي موظف يخرج من هذا الباب الذي
تراه امامي هذه هذه بوابه الرئيسيه ما بين
همم وسائل الاعلام الامريكي
حتى التصريحات من قبل الشركه باختصار حسين
اذا تكرم
هنا هناك طبعا يعني طالما ان الشركه لا
تريد ان تتحدث هناك حاله انستغرام
الاعلام الامريكي يحصل على على المعلومات
من خلال موظفين اما السابقين او بعض
الموظفين الذين ما زالوا في الحقيقه
يعملون هنا ولكن عندما يتحدثون يتحدثون
شرطا لا يتم الكشف عن اسمهم هناك حاله
استغراب دائما الاعلام الامريكي يقول ايضا
بانه يتواصل مع الشركه من اجل الحصول على
اجوبه لكنها شركه تلتزم الصمدي هناك حاله
صامت مطلقه في الحقيقه همم هي ما تثير همم
تزيد الغموض حول ما يجري همم شكرا جزيلا
حسين الطود مراسل العربيه من سان
فرانسيسكو
[موسيقى]
من جد عبد الله الدرويش فايز ويلا بعد
الفوز التاريخي للمنتخب السعودي على نظير
الارجنتيني ضمن كاس العالم في قطر بثنائيه
لهدف واحد
افتتحت بل افتتحت ابرز الصحف العالميه
اعدادها بالحديث عن النتيجه
الاخضر السعودي امام رفاق الاسطوره ليونيل
ميسي
في المونديال ما زال حديث الكل ويثير ردود
الافعال ثنائيه امام المنتخب
وتستعمل كلماته للتعبير عن اداء ابهر
الجميع امام رفاق صاحب الكره الذهبيه
السبعه انها اللدغه العربيه
صدر صفحتها الاولى وتابعت بالقول ميسي
يفشل في تحقيق الفوز ضد السعوديه في احدى
مفاجات كاس العالم حيث خصيره الارجنتين
لاول مره في اخر ثلاث سنوات اما صحيفه
الجارديانا البريطانيه فعلقت الدوسري بطل
صدمه زلزال في المانيا
تصدم الارجنتين بهدفين متتاليين وتلحق بها
الهزيمه صحيفه ماركه الاسبانيه قنبله
ناريه تاريخيه في وجه الارجنتين فيما كتبت
صحيفه وديبورتيفو الاسبانيه ايضا ضربه
قويه للارجنتين امام السعوديه اما صحيفه
انت البرازيليه فقد وضع تعليقا طريفا على
النتيجه بقولها شكرا للمملكه العربيه
السعوديه جعلتم صباحنا جميلا في البرازيل
شكرا لكم من 200 مليون برازيلي
هي اذا مباراه ستبقى راسخه في اذان
المشجعين السعوديين والعرب وفي كل انحاء
العالم بعد ان كتب الاخضر السعودي بدايته
في المونديال بمداد من ذهب
دربنا اخضر بلال البوجداني العربيه
[موسيقى]
سكانها من تحت ركام زلازل يعيدون بناء
سقفا ويحتمون به ياتي زلزال اخر ليدمر
بيوتهم من جديد ويسرق منهم احبائهم فيجدون
انفسهم في العرائب مره اخرى في اخر
الزلازل في اخر الزلازل ضرب المقاطعه
الاندونيسيه ارتفع عدد الوفيات الى اكثر
من
2868 شخصا وخلف اثار دمار واسعه وانهيار
نحو 22000
منزلت قريه كامله تحت الارض
[موسيقى]
بعد صور رجاوي وهذا الدمار نذكركم بابراج
العناوين
استنفار الامنيه شمال سوريا وعزو الامريكي
والروسيه يمنع وقف التوغل التركيه وهي
تترك الاكراده تحت النيران
مفاجات كاس العالم مستمره منتخب الساموراي
يهزم الالمان والماتادور الاسباني يدق
المرمى الكوستاريكي بسباعيه
فئران حرب شوارع في المدن الكرديه نظام
يرفع وتيره القمه والمحتجون يردون بالدعوه
لاضراب العام
تها العسكريه ورساله ضغط جديده على اداره
اوكرانيا
شكرا لكم لطيب المتابعه القاكم بعد قليل
في مجازا اخباري في امان الله
[موسيقى]